fare stare
[Applauso]
rosario sanno cosa non sa usare lo sanno
usare osama sanno osare usano sanno
series banda usare osama osanna cosaro
series usa ma
ama osare ama osare osanna osare osare
osare
buongiorno è un grande onore per me
essere qui questo importante evento
perché faccio questa specie di
sciocchezza all'inizio
lo faccio per usare
avrei potuto non rischiare fare un
incipit più tradizionale non fare questa
specie di sciocchezza a usare a volte
implica fare qualche specie di
sciocchezza ma allora usiamo la macchina
del tempo visto che oramai siamo
nell'era in cui saremo la vigilia di
poter usare realmente la macchina del
tempo
torniamo indietro un attimo e
ricominciamo perché così sarà la vostra
memoria sensoriale a decidere quale
incipit sedimenterà di bimbo
buongiorno grande onore gioia essere qui
in questo importante evento
cominciamo subito col dire che osare è
la parola chiave nella vita che a sua
volta vita è l'alternanza degli opposti
noi viviamo perché cerchiamo di
armonizzare l'odio l'amore la donna e
l'uomo il giorno e la notte
osare porta ad armonizzare esaltare
questi opposti il che è il risultato più
augurabile meravigliosa
lo si fa grazie anche all'intuizione che
cos'è l'intuizione lo vogliamo chiedere
ci risponderanno con la radice della
parola perché intuisco no dimmi che
cos'è l'intuizione dell'intuizione a una
definizione alchemica ben precisa
l'intuizione è immaginazione più forza
di volontà cioè io ho una visione vedo
qualche cosa che voglio raggiungere ma
ci metto tutta la mia forza per cercare
di concretizzare di plasmare questa
visione è questo questo si chiama osare
oltre all immaginazione lo si fa anche
grazie alla follia sana alla follia
quella che ha portato albert einstein a
dire che l'immaginazione è più
importante della conoscenza pensate che
frasi importanti questa così oggi ho
preferito in qualche modo leggere
qualche mio pensiero poesia per
contribuire con piccoli semi di una
visione sentimentale visione
sentimentale per me la chiave ad oggi
anche per come sta andando al mondo come
sta andando il mondo in questi ultimi
tre anni in una società dove economia e
politica continuano a inanellare
sovente sistematici prevedibili
fallimenti dovuti a quella forma mentis
un po limitata dei settori è imperativo
l'avvento in questi settori stessi di
fantasia immaginazione visione
umanistica sono elementi genetici e
importanti dei settori artistici e solo
la compenetrazione di questi due settori
economia politica e visione artistica
potrà dare veramente una risposta a
questa eredità una sorte di aridità
endemica del prossimo immediato futuro
sull'invenzione della materia l'uomo ha
raggiunto dei livelli oramai quasi
saturi e quindi ecco che passiamo al
virtuale ma stiamo attenti perché in
qualche modo irrituale del virtuale può
farci stallare può correre il rischio di
farci staccare dalla realtà armonica e
di passare a quella sofisticazione che a
volte diventa diventa mistificazione
quindi andiamo in qualche modo
evidenziare l'insoddisfazione per
l'armonia naturale delle cose questo è
il peccato originale ad oggi è il nostro
peccato originale contemporaneo
allora mi sembra in qualche modo di
assistere con una pentola in ebollizione
che ti attrae di a vincere con questo
suo continuo rumorio con questo suo
continuo magma ma anche sonoro però guai
a berla guai a bere quell'acqua bollente
può essere pericolosa è quella che poi
ci porta alle guerre e quella che ci
porta a sacrificare nel tempo esistenza
eccellenti partendo dalla figura di
cristo arrivando a gambe a martin luther
king junior ai fratelli kennedy aizen
rabin e benazir bhutto include in questa
catena di persone straordinarie
esistenze anche le figure di per paolo
pasolini e john lennon perché perché
hanno parlato di armonia degli opposti
hanno parlato di pace hanno combattuto
questa equazione oramai ci dicono che è
ineluttabile cioè la guerra cioè la non
con diversa fra colori culture e in
qualche modo provenienze diverse
e allora io vi dico benvenuto benvenuto
vento del pulito onore perché tra voglie
ricordi io ho troppo il mondo dentro di
me e noi abbiamo troppo il mondo dentro
di noi per poter quietare noi dobbiamo
osare
anche se ogni tanto mi piace indulgere a
questo dolcissimo sentimento che si
avverte nel perdere come un te ne un
tenero abbandono al fluire e forse la
dichiarazione probabile di non
appartenenza a questi codici regnanti
chissà e il probabile comprendere che
forse siamo arrivati per caso su questo
mondo ci siamo finalmente riconosciuti e
abbiamo visto ogni tanto ha riconosciuto
l'inganno di un percorso che non è
nostro
con questo nostro desiderio vero
visibile solo nello specchietto
retrovisore del nostro viaggio l'abbiamo
superato quel desiderio ci siamo
obbligati a superarlo e questo non va
bene senza accorgersi
forse che
fermandoci una stazione di servizio lo
vediamo ripassare lo vediamo sempre in
quello specchietto retrovisore
ma questo è gettare la spugna beh non
dobbiamo farlo perché anzi questo forse
il saluto finale alla solitudine è una
pausa su quel cammino che forse
intimamente non ci appartiene e che sta
durando troppo anche solo per comprare
una confezione di finta distratta
felicità prima di pagare alla cassa di
quella stazione di servizio e uscire
dalla stazione stessa senza niente in
tasca e questo è osare
vedete molte volte io ripasso qui in un
incrocio che sta vicino a questo
edificio vicino la mia casa come quando
da giovane veniva qua in questo scuola
e questi ricordi li danno in qualche
modo un aiuto dell'inconscio un io un
aiuto per arrivare a quella allora che
mi ha portato lontano con l'allora che
così vicino qua nello spazio e nel tempo
è sempre lì quella allora è sempre lì a
farmi osare
puntuale nel dirmi che una radice si
riforma anche se non la strappi o anche
se invece la strappi con tutta la tua
forza
anche se la terra intorno a te magari
chissà non è più così buona come allora
è sempre lì puntuale a giustificare i
tuoi impedimenti ma reclama in cambio
una visione e un percorso di concreta
riuscita e su che cosa si può gina
questo percorso sulla dolcezza che
risponde alla vita vera
a quella apparentemente impossibile vita
vera
sembra uno stridente gioco di
equilibrismo di convivenza tra ciò che
sai che è reale e ciò che può esserlo in
forma sublime se solo questo reale
asciutto arido e costretto dall'esterno
venisse vinto dalle lacrime bagnate
l'acri bagnate di coraggio in coscienza
di una sana e matura anziana gioventù e
di una giovane anzianità questo amici
miei e osare perché il tempo ti tratta
in risposta alle rose che tu gli offri
seppur spinose sanguinanti perché hanno
i petali ancor più rossi per la
testimonianza che uscendo dalle veneti
che la strada è un rivolo rosso sulla
neve su questa neve che tanto qua ci è
familiare preciso denso è un
protagonista vivo che si staglia dalla
purezza fretta
ti parla chiedendoti chi sei c'è ancora
voglia di osare e perché mai quella
distesa candita ad oggi è imbrattata di
diverso colore rosso sangue
allora
uno degli errori più grandi della vita
che facciamo è quello di dire facciamo
l'amore
chiave di tutto anche nelle circostanze
più meritevoli ma che vuoi mai fare
l'amore non si fa l'amore si percepisce
poi si espande non si è mai fatto
l'amore è l'amore non si è mai fatto
fare
allora vengono strani pensieri quali
meglio non mettere al mondo nessuno ma
aiutare chi già c'è
senza averlo chiesto e lui bambino non
sa se riuscirà a sopravvivere
però dobbiamo usare dobbiamo credere
nella continuazione della vita perché
poi come è successo a milano lo scorso
18 dicembre alle 11 44 e non solo a
milano ma io ero li vedi la tazzina del
caffè che comincia a tremare e avverti
10 secondi di terremoto
e allora capisce ancora di più che la
vita è fatta di piccolissimi
meravigliosi reali momenti la vita è
fatta soprattutto
di fantasia l'immaginazione è fatta di
osare di maestri antichi di draghi di
agorà di bellezza
tutti elementi dignitosi che ti portano
coraggio e forza
questo è usare la vita non e fatta
invece
nell'ascoltare gli influencer come oro
colato perché questo non è usare questo
si chiama l'abilità
dobbiamo svegliarci per vivere un altro
giorno ma non solo per quello ma
piuttosto per vivere il tempo di una
lunghissima giornata che significa il
tempo maturato e poi lasciato in eredità
a volte siamo e desidererei davvero non
esserlo preda della speranza è tremenda
questa speranza ogni tanto e più
ostinata della morte con i suoi alti e
bassi che ti fanno invocare la tragedia
addirittura quasi per fermare
quell'altalena sublime dell'anima che
fermare tanto non si può e tende le sue
due corde all'interno dell'unica tenda
del cuore vuota nel suo tra sudare al
colmo queste polli e gioiosa la follia
gioiosa bisogna usarla fino alla fine è
lei la vera medicina
perché sa trasformare quelle due corde
dell'altalena dell'anima in aste di
meravigliose note che reggono un legno
che suona di vento e respiro di
beatitudine e di mai più paura ti mai
più paura
il pianeta dove le cose non importano
più di tanto e dove si continua
incoscientemente
ineluttabilmente a dosare sono i bambini
che c'era insegnano tutto sommato il
regalo più grande che tu puoi fare al
cielo a chi ti ha messo al mondo è
quello di far loro capire che percepisci
ancora una speranza è che puoi
continuare ad usare
lo so queste parole si perderanno nel
vento come milioni di parole di migliore
di persone che nella storia sono state
mosse da meravigliose intenzioni
però ricorda fini o mio è un dio non
chiede che dio vorrai mi basta sapere
che credi per sempre da mai così
ammiraglio santo portami dove anche i
sogni divampano l'ardore e per il tempo
che sai nel ruvido vanto prova seguirmi
tra i meandri lisci da quando ti
implorai impedisci il dolore e di
punirmi
e allora dolce amore dimmi che cosa ti
accadrà se una volta ancorati
obbligheranno a mare tu creda gli all in
faccia non lo spiegare mai che un umano
e vivo soltanto se sa usare
io mi chiamo alberto fortis sono nato
qui a domodossola mi hanno istruito qua
in questo collegio e ho portato la mia
musica nel mondo
perché ho subito il fascino
ho creduto nello usare grazie
[Applauso]